hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i want
to go through
amc's price action guys for the past two
days a lot of things happen
it's definitely not looking good so
i don't want to let you down in this bad
time let's have a look at everything
that happened here
and let's try to understand what this
means in terms of
future price action let's get into it
all right guys so here everything has
changed as you can see
all right my initial analysis was not uh
good here i mean the outcome was not
good i thought
that you know basically there was this
bull trap so let me just show you
quickly guys
uh what's the reason why i was bullish
here i was playing this breakout all
right guys for those who watch my
previous video i was playing this break
after right
so whenever you have a breakout usually
then you have the pullback that was here
expected
to do you know 61.8 percent retracement
so basically 37 so you know when the
market corrected to 37 i was like yeah
this is okay
i personally took a trade here about 37
i bought 35
as well i shared this trade with you
guys on my discord
and then things were not looking good
you know i explained in my previous
video that basically we had those
weaknesses uh what i call weaknesses is
everything that is unusual
in this kind of reversal so this is the
first weakness we shouldn't have gone to
35
we should have stayed above so first
weakness
second weakness here the market managed
to go higher and then broke
again uh so second weakness sorry it's
here
um and in this area i guess i told you
on my discord that between 31 and 35 i'm
not taking any trades i'm out of my
trade i stopped lost my position at 34.5
this is the reason why i'm always using
your stop loss because you know the
market is tricky
and this is also the reason why it's
good to diversify your uh
investment and when i'm gonna start my
live training with you guys of course i
will you know pick up some trades on amc
gme yeah i mean you know this is the
stocks you guys want to see so i want to
you know show you that we can trade it
too but you know not
just buying and holding it's going to be
a dynamic
management and of course there's gonna
be many other stocks
all right uh because of course one
analysis can you know give you a signal
that finally is not happening this is
the
reason why we use a stop loss and if you
do many analysis in the long run
you are making money so this is uh the
project that
i'm starting here but let's go back to
the technicals so here
second weakness and then 31 guys and
let's have a look at what happened at 31
guys it's very interesting
so it broke bam strongly volumes up
volumes are a bit higher yesterday okay
we have this here increasing volume at
31 all right it's a breakout so of
course there is an increase in the
volumes
it's not spectacular you know it's
nothing
really really much bigger than the rest
of the
volume traded that day but it confirms
we have the breakout we have the re-test
you know here as we often do so it's a
very short-term retest expect a
longer-term retest guys later
but for now we have this retest here and
then we just moved lower
so what is the situation now let's go
back on our little frame
uh we have weakness guys we have
weakness and so first thing
like i said in my mc recaps below 31
okay here the breakout was already
weakened
very weakened but still this breakout
was valid we could still have a one
two and then a three now that we made a
new low all right below 31 we have made
a new law so this
it means that this breakout is not a
breakout it is invalidated
it was just a pullback of the of the
correction that is still ongoing
it means that this whole correction is
still
ongoing unfortunately so of course there
was a trick
on the upside there was a [ __ ] maybe
this is a bear trap all right maybe this
is a bear trap
so i i really hope it is but uh once
again i'm here trying to make
you know the best and the nicest i can
i'm using my tools i'm applying it to
amc
for those who are following me for a
long time you know that it gave me very
good results uh for a very long time
and i have to say that for the past
three weeks
uh it's you know very hard it's very
tricky so that there are many reasons
behind it maybe you know
some big investors anticipate what
technicals are gonna give you and
they're just you know go against it
it's for example what i'm hearing a lot
i'm not sure about that but yeah why not
it's possible all right it's possible so
whatever the reason behind it's very
tricky so maybe this is one more trick
of the market and it's gonna revert
right away
but this is not for me the preferred
scenario
so i'm going to give here what i think
might happen
okay so we have weakness here 31 has not
been retested uh yet
it's like you know for example here you
can see 2d5
it has been tested so broken retested
retested
broken retested so it's going to act
many times so i expect 21 to be retested
next week or something like this for now
we are weak so i expect
you know some maybe more downside
movements we have some support at 27
so maybe we're gonna go take it maybe go
to 31
and then i think we're going to hover
and finally go to 24
before here seeing maybe some more
bullish momentum coming back and you
know moving like this
so this is uh kind of the typical
uh situation that we would see happening
here we are looking for as i was
discussing guys on my discord
so bam bam we are looking for here
for some bullish divergence guys so
usually at the end of this kind of moves
we have those kind of divergences all
right
so here you can see that here we don't
have it between here and here there is
still weakness
between here and here for now we have it
but this move down is not complete so
let's see
how low the macd is going when the
smooth down is going to be complete
then there's going to be probably a
small rebound then i'm afraid you know
i don't think the strong rebound would
happen before you know the
end end of august all right something
like you know in
two three weeks because once again i
don't think this correction is complete
and now the this breakout has been
invalidated so we're looking for
a new one and we're gonna set up a trade
as usual
after breakout on a pullback so i'm
gonna wait
here so either here there is a nice
trade to
to try
you know in this area again with stop
loss guys you know by 24 25
i would use a tight stop loss around 20
23.5
you know something like this and i would
try to get in like at the lows
and if i don't get executed here i would
wait for this breakout guys all right
and here there's gonna be another
breakout
and this would be another opportunity to
enter this trade in the
with some bullish momentum with probably
some good news we have the earnings
coming uh next week
so you know many things can happen and
entering here
is a nice try so for now what i've been
doing
so since uh you know i i quit my job i
can you know
let's say take some trades i'm gonna
mostly take trades
uh for my portfolio that i'm going to
show you guys on my discord
but i can tell you that i have already
taken uh one trade on amc like i said
between uh 37
and 35 so here okay i took this trade
and bam bam i got here i got
out of the trade at 34.5 so now i have
no position
and i'm gonna try to build up a long
position here and
here so here is gonna be a very nice
position for example to do this
option strategy that i showed you guys
already selling a put when the
volatility is very high
is a very good timing to buy a call here
it's going to be a bit
maybe here just buy shares all right so
here i would do my uh
sell food bike buy a cold spread so sell
the
24 foot maybe i would go slightly lower
but sell it the 24 put and buy maybe you
know a 30 call
because i guess it would be like kind of
even i can even buy you know more calls
if i sell
24 put i i will update you guys if we go
there alright we have time
it's going to be next week in two weeks
and if we come here
then here i would only buy shares
because the option strategy here
makes less sense so once again um you
know
trading is like this you cannot be
always right what is very important is
to always have a plan
to always know what you're going to do
so for example as far as i'm concerned
here
i'm out of my trade because i planned
that this can happen
so i put i use the stop loss and here i
have a plan
to do something here and i have a plan
to do something here this is the kind of
things that we're gonna show you guys
when we're gonna start to trade live
uh by the way very quickly guys i'm
gonna reopen uh the discord memberships
this weekend for everyone for now it's
only available for people
on my discord by the way thank you very
much guys for coming you know so quickly
on this
memberships i'm sorry as well about the
mess that happened at the beginning
you know i didn't want too many people
to come here so you know i could take
care of everyone
properly so there are still available uh
places for those who are already in the
discord for those who are not on the
discord
you're gonna have some places available
this weekend so in
three days so i will keep you updated
guys and that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys